I'm on the islands of Hawaii an idyllic
destination for honeymooners Hollywood
blockbusters and now Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg his own private sanctuary but
there's a dark side to this paradise
that Zuckerberg has brought to light a
century long battle over land that began
when American plantation owners
overthrew the Hawaiian Kingdom so now a
billionaire comes in with his money
doing it by for removing people out of
their land we see these sort of things
going on every day where what little lab
that was left for us now is up for grabs
this is a rock wall Zuckerberg shelves
around his 700 acre property and just to
give you some perspective here you could
fit more than 500 football fields inside
it's one thing to want to protect your
property it's another when Native
Hawaiians like Shannon Buckner still own
pieces of your land so the land that you
own is just across this fence right here
yeah but Mark Zuckerberg has put up this
wall and fence and it says no
trespassing yeah what would happen if
you tried to go over there I'll get
arrested for trespassing even though
it's your land yep
Chanin is among countless Native
Hawaiians who own inherited lands called
kuleana which means responsibility
individual parcels can sometimes be
small but they're owned collectively and
are meant to ensure Native ownership in
perpetuity
the problem is kuleana lands are passed
down through the generations without a
will or d the lack of paper trail means
some defendants don't even know they own
land other times under a complicated
legal system called quiet titles a buyer
like Zuckerberg can sue cliana owners to
force them to sell their land usually at
auction for pennies on the dollar and
that's just what he did suing hundreds
and infuriating many more ironically I
mean he knows us well for privacy and
it's just attracting more people here's
always famous for now they know what
property Hill's Keola Worthington is one
of the descendants of the land
Zuckerberg has walled off the Facebook
CEO kato reported 100 million dollars to
buy the land in 2014 which includes a
former sugarcane plantation and a beach
previously owned by a millionaire you
know capitalism or white man style I
call it there needs to be one owner a
one man needs the power and authority to
just control everything it's kind of
like a repeat of the overthrow of Hawaii
another overthrow of our people and land
that's how many Native Hawaiians see it
when word got out about the lawsuits
they called out Zuckerberg using his own
platform they even made videos and memes
blasting him
Zuckerberg apologized and dropped his
lawsuits we reached out multiple times
for comment and were sent an op-ed he
wrote saying he'll talk to the community
and find a better approach but many told
us the damage is already done we have a
hard time sleeping since this came up
it's always on your mind card to page or
not when you have a billionaire site
carry Ferrara's cousin sold her land for
$400 to a company called North Shore
Colo LLC not realizing it's owned by
Zuckerberg then his attorney called
Terry his first words out of his mouth
was how does it feel to get $800 for
land that you'd never knew you had
and we assume we're selling to a collar
farmer we're like yeah it sounds good
kalo is the Hawaiian word for taro a
plant that's sacred to Native Hawaiians
it's central to their creation story and
is a staple food in its pounded form and
then you found out that North Shore
Callao LLC is Mark Zuckerberg yeah
company yes and how did you feel when
you found that out I was mad I was upset
I felt deceived will you sell the lamp
no I love it he can get he can offer me
$100,000 I won't take it tell me why
because it's our culture that's our
native land and just to preserve it what
you see here in Hawaii now with all the
buildings and just the overdevelopment
we're overcrowded quite is not like how
it used to be the problem of land loss
is bigger than Zuckerberg it's been
happening since American plantation
owners led a coup overthrowing the
Hawaiian Kingdom in 1893 radio host
Kalani mahouka faults the Hawaiian state
she calls illegitimate for facilitating
the land grab this allows a wealthy land
owner or someone with money to come in
and essentially point out a piece of
land and say dude that's looking real
good for me I think I want that land hmm
oh oh
pesky Hawaiian Coolio no land oh oh how
do we get rid of them how do we get the
masculine fake state of away comes along
and says no problem rich guy there's a
process called quiet title Kalani hosts
a weekly radio show called songs of
sovereignty where she talked about all
the land issues Native Hawaiians face
today if you had one message for
Americans who live on the mainland who
see Hawaii as if paradise this vacation
destination for their honeymoons or
whatever would it be we want to share
our home with people what we want you to
go home after you've visited stop moving
here you need to stop moving here
because we have nowhere to live
[Music]
the uproar over zuckerberg lawsuits
prompted state representative Kahn
yelling to introduce a bill that would
force anyone pursuing quiet title to
enter mediation with the families first
this is the same tool that's been used
for over 200 years on the sugar Barons
the plantation owners used to use it to
strip Hawaiian land from white hands and
we need to put it into this for the girl
because the legal system is stacked
against them some Native Hawaiians have
resorted to occupying their kuleana
lands Jessie Steele's ancestral land in
Hawaii was sold by the state to
mainlander this is one of many
occupations or a job yes how many
occupations are there a lot this is our
lifestyle you see all this Carol and
stuff we eat this stuff this is all food
right here how does it make you feel
that someone from the outside who can
afford it can you just come and buy this
sacred land where your ancestors are
buried makes me know I've I get really
mixed much angry all like the new house
is on and high and all vacationer until
kind like are they dig up the plans you
know in a day they know they don't treat
it as if it was an archaeological site
though like it though they'll take the
bones away and they'll still put the
septic system in and they'll be sitting
right where our bones were you know amid
the anger one thing is clear zuckerberg
may have cast the biggest spotlight yet
on Native Hawaiians fighting to hold on
to their land and all too often losing
in your ideal scenario how would this
all be resolved how does all play out if
he would just let us keep our loan
hello hi guys it's Tina in Hawaii and I
hope you enjoyed this last video about
Native Hawaiians fighting for their
ancestral land make sure you check out
this next video about the broader fight
for sovereignty here and let me know
what you think in the comments